[Music]
and let it go news
oh yeah you need to do that submitted by
king of kings
oh damn joe you got competition he's the
queen remember
oh yeah you're the queen now the queen
of kings a study finds that people often
stay in relationships because they fear
their partner will fall apart without
them
what the [ __ ] i know that's a fact [ __ ]
no i don't believe in that bart's doing
it because he doesn't want jio to cry
i know i wouldn't survive with that you
told me that literally to my face
what the [ __ ] you're like repeat it
you're like my life would end without
you
is that what i said yeah was i trying to
be romantic or was i being like very
like we were having a very serious
conversation i think
both times mom and dad are fighting but
i
think i talk all this [ __ ] and i'm like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] leave but
not today i feel like i feel bad
one of my exes had like depression and
like
i i know what that's like and he's so
nice i just couldn't like it was
he was a really nice guy and we didn't
have anything wrong and we never
fought or anything but we just been
together so long and we like
grew apart and i just didn't wasn't
attracted to him anymore like in a
sexual i loved him like i cared about
him but i didn't
i wasn't in love with him yeah like a
like a sibling maybe
i'm like the opposite when i actually
love someone i'm always trying to leave
what do you mean
because it's a logical thing because
it's kind of like oh we're getting too
[ __ ] close
you know you might they might leave you
yeah you should have therapy whether i
like him or not i think i'm always
trying to leave we're telling him that
we've all been telling him so ricky he
knows he tells himself that
i don't need that reppy i think you do i
just need matcha tea
ass sip you can get it right here you
don't need to [ __ ] worry about
problems just sip them away
sip away your your tears oh man
all right so this university of utah
psychologist
wanted to take a more optimistic
look at leaving and staying in
relationships and so what she did is
her and her team she surveyed and
tracked 1
348 people in relationships over the
course of 10 weeks
and then they looked at traditional
reasons for staying
like their sense of commitment to the
other person or how much time and
energy they had invested in the
relationship and how much
they would lose if they left and
concerns
over not finding an alternative partner
and then they also asked about the
pro-social component
of remaining relationships that were not
fulfilling
and then they found that the perceptions
of the other partner's
commitment predicted staying more than
anything else
so if the other partner was like or
if let's say if i can see that casey's
way more invested way more committed
into the relationship but i'm not really
feeling it but because i know how
he feels about it then i'll stay for him
oh that makes sense do you think that's
more women than men
yes um they didn't really mention that i
feel like it is
i feel like it is because it seems like
it's more intuitive for women to
do those sacrifices biologically that
sounds very nurturing
yeah yeah like even though at your
expense to make someone happy
like or you don't want them to go
through so much that you'll just suffer
yeah you empathize more so you don't
want to feel them to feel pain
and i also have been through so you know
before my job was like lash extensions
that's what i used to do so you get to
talk to a lot of people for like a long
time and a lot of the women will say
like i'm not with the love of my life
but i'm with someone who's
like consistent loyal respectful like
who
gets like the check marks even though i
don't get all they don't know they can
find the love of their life and the
check marks
i don't think everybody does which is a
very it's hard work though
i don't think everybody does and a lot
of times people stay for comfort and
that's okay and it's allowed you know
yeah that's why the doctor was saying
that it's hard to show
that it's like a truly selfless act like
by
making sure that the other person's
happy and staying in a relationship that
the person doesn't want to be in because
there's also like self-interest there's
a big blur because even when you do
charity
it's like you think it's a selfless act
but it actually makes you feel good you
feel good about yourself like i'm a good
person
for me that's why i do the opposite i do
crime so then i go
i'm a good person for me it did not make
me feel more comfortable to be with him
um even though i mean financially like
we were splitting rent like i guess
maybe that would be the only
plus but it it made me feel like i was a
bad person
right because you're lying to yourself
yeah basically like it was
almost like i was cheating on him with
myself i can't live with a lie anymore
yeah and is it really like doing him any
good if i'm staying with him
but we're not i'm not really intimate
with him anymore because i just
how old were you at this time i was 23.
right so you were super young and at
that point you look at yourself and
you're like i got at least
10 more years yeah to go and meet you
know at least 10 more years
to find a good partner to find someone
to have kids with to find someone that's
going to meet you
like i meant to live i was like well i
mean i hope so got one more year left
if you ask like a 55 year old that if
she's in a relationship with someone her
whole life with four kids or whatever
she's gonna look at you and be like well
[ __ ] it at least he's faithful or like
at least
bringing food to the table or at least
he's keeping up with you know what i
mean like i think it's also what you
prioritize in a relationship for sure
for me like um intimacy and like
feeling that like closeness with someone
is number one
and i don't care about money i don't
care about um like you know whatever
other circumstances i guess i've never
had kids so i don't know
it might change things for me but yeah
because then it's all about the survival
yeah yeah and like protecting your
family and stuff but like it just
i'm not doing anyone any favors if we're
both not happy if i'm not happy the
relationship
you can't be happy how can you be happy
if you're with someone that doesn't want
to be with you
yeah and that's self-love and i felt
like that was yeah
yeah even though it hurt it did hurt him
but like
it was better in the long run because
now you're like free now you can find
someone that will love you back right
especially because you have the luxury
to do it why not go to the full extent
because there's some people that are
like well i need to get a citizenship to
a new country because i'm in a shitty
position so they just marry
or like they're so poor that the only
way they can get
up in the world is like well let me
marry somebody because i don't have
education or whatever right so there's
that too
but yeah like i really came down to our
five year anniversary was coming up
and i knew he was going to propose or
like he was talking about it
that makes you wake up yeah when i when
i thought about like
like vowing to spend the rest of my life
with him i was like
it's just not going to work and so yeah
i broke up with him the day before our
five year anniversary
why'd you wait up until then because i
couldn't do it it was like so hard
it's hard to do that it's hard to break
someone's heart because you're just like
oh my god you're just like this little
tiny thing
who's like love me and i can't
physically love and there was no reason
there wasn't like you cheated on me or
like you were bad or we've been fighting
there was no reason other than if you
can't picture your future with that
person you gotta get away
yeah you gotta it's not it just doesn't
make any sense to spend more time on it
like thinking of having sex with him
made me want to throw up
like wow that's bad i was gonna say
[ __ ] i'm into that
but oh now you don't want to cuss the
whole day i don't say that
i'm just kidding no but i think i've
been through that too and i think your
body will tell you
but like again we're so young and we
have well you're married now but i'm not
and we have so much
we don't have as much to lose and back
then because i was in a similar
situation like i would literally lay
next to this person and get like itchy
like yeah
don't [ __ ] touch me we complain about
it and i and the more he'd complain the
less attracted i was
oh yeah dude literally like i [ __ ]
hope you know
this but like he would try to cuddle and
like i would just be like like i can't
like don't touch me you know wow and i
think like that other person lacks
self-love or
you know they don't show themselves
stuff so they're like no you're the best
thing i can do like i don't want to
leave you
and you're like trust me there's better
out there there's someone who's gonna
feel this way for you
he started losing his identity too he
would be like we'd be at a social event
and he would be like
i'm nikki's boyfriend instead of i'm he
wouldn't even say his name first [ __ ] no
introduce himself as nikki's boyfriend
so what this boils down to
is selfless women don't want no [ __ ]
i mean yeah i mean at least not these
two no
yeah exactly you can't generalize all
women yeah i mean for sure
i don't know it just it just what it
sounds like is y'all just completely
lost respect
and you want something else kind of yeah
when we got together
it was like he was a trainer like he had
been leading this organization
and stuff and like i thought that was
attractive and then when
he moved to la with me he didn't do any
of that and so he just it's like that
drive and that energy
it's like if they're lacking that it's
like dude you went from king to peasant
yeah oh yeah i study i like to study
relationships a lot and like look into
them
and that's one of the things that i
enjoy to do and so the main thing in any
relationship whether it's like work
friendship romantic
is respect like that's the core of any
successful relationship
and once i respect this loss there's
nothing
outside of that you know because once i
lose respect for you and in an argument
i start calling you a [ __ ] all the time
like in a romantic like uh relationship
specifically like
then i can just go to that every time
and then you lose yourself value your
self-love and your self-respect
that's true so yeah i respect i talk a
lot of [ __ ] when i fight i got to stop
doing that you really do though
that's a lot of harm dude and then words
will never be forgotten they'll be
forgiven but they'll never be forgotten
i'm just thinking hey i'm not throwing
fist huh
so i'm doing the peaceful parts her
worst
emotional draw traumas so i should go
go hands with jesus what the [ __ ] is
that one or the other there are like a
million other options you should go to
therapy
i'm right there with you i but i learned
that for
girls uh words speak louder than actions
for sure 100 because i think for dudes
it's like you cannot be honest you can
call your homie
like the f word all the time right you
[ __ ] [ __ ] i hate you whatever but
if every time we're getting like i'm
covering the bill if he ever needs
something let him borrow my car
like the homie the homie trust you know
through actions but for girls i learned
it's like you
can buy her everything you can do all
the actions and be really loving but
if you don't have the words there's
nothing there well
no not necessarily it's a balance it's
not nothing exactly
what the [ __ ] there's perspective like i
can be sitting here right now and be
like [ __ ] shut up you know but if we're
in an argument and i'm like look [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
yeah that changes the tone and even i
call each other [ __ ] all the time when
we're loving each other right right
if we're in the fight we don't we don't
name call or any
like anything like that we curse a lot
but we don't name them calls try not to
i do yeah we scream [ __ ] you at each
other but
we also say [ __ ] you when we leave each
other so like
like when we say bye like
[ __ ] you honey [ __ ] you back bye bish
we used to say that we were saying thank
you instead of thank you we said [ __ ]
you very much
[Music]